another one you get a lot of presents
[Music]
[Music]
and her visit I'm so excited like I'm
always going to visit Florida I'm more
excited because the fact I'm going to
see my cousin's now I'm also excited
because I've always wanted to go to
Florida BB is started collection here
where line are we flying Isaac ah
alright debris said about this place
because I multiply we've ever done which
members and virtual bride neurosurgeon
thank us all about the queen of books
purchases and always been
Jenkins we clearly could paul riesling
all the rings and I thought so I'm also
kind of excited to use the CP videos you
have to say Britain's
safety videos like really really for
which we have friends that were featured
in a semi then like like seen my plane
just pretty
three hours of sleep last night
a little bit
honey wait
I'm seconds on twisting like this
and it is like
pretty excited to be back in Florida
because I actually spent two years
living in Florida school been back man
so excited to be back it's really using
a plane you were now
[Music]
[Music]
he makes you look really old now baby
good he's like who are you Thank You
bhai
alright so I I'm still like so
fangirling that I saw William Levy right
in front of me if you guys don't know
who he is he's like this huge Latin
America actor model perfection of life
like oh my God he's a lot in KP already
knows it's so funny for my Casey I will
drop you in a second for him he's right
there I think I was just kidding he was
like oh so get a picture with him I'm
like
now I regret it I really are gently
getting implicate embarrassed or nervous
or what stuff like that
I was wondering yeah how does that make
you feel did you get Dulles did you get
Dallas why can't a mother jealous
you became a beauty you're kind of
getting a little jealous yeah because I
was trying to whisper right until
keeping him raving invoices a whole want
to take a picture with it I want you
take it like Ruby I oh my gosh I'm so
alike blusters and then I was texting
Jenny I'm like oh my god Jenny William
Levy is right in front of a company that
like seeing William Levy is like seeing
like the Brad Pitt of Latin America all
right so this is a fun I sent Betty so
if you guys see closely that is William
Levy I'm such a creeper we should have
gone to picture home we should have
chased them down as soon as he got his
luggage and just gone waiting where oh
well I have and now we get to celebrate
our reunion my beautiful beautiful
cousin you know technically she's
actually my aunt I guess I don't know
like Sequoia cousins our mood is amazing
I'm your aunt not a my giant Isaac
Branden basil so the way we're related
is Jenni's mom is my grandma's sister
Denny's actually my dad's cousin but
we've always grown up like so to be
younger than me so I'm like you're like
you know Hansel reflects okay yeah okay
right that's right
any why yeah go to watch lots of you
guys one more today what time is it
[Music]
good morning today the first full day in
Florida with my beautiful cousin Jenny
and then you guys forget though right
now we're about to eat like it on time
because Casey would you like to tell
these people why we're eating here but
Ron Hawkes is a secret rule of Florida
it is Peruvian food and it's also the
one rush on that note three great years
are probably ain't there like once a day
I just duper bomb it's really affordable
and I miss it to relent his memories are
going to eat here for our first meal all
right so the chicken here is really good
but the one thing I miss the most is
actually this right here this stuff
right here oh that is why I came here
for college for 95 one special just
cannot beat that
how many days were you in college two
years so 265 what is it me neither the
campus
[Music]
bringing in beyond those videos by the
way don't touch your lender all right so
this time I like to eat it I take the
rice I throw defeated Internet throw the
salt in Hana carry Aden
yeah we're carrying from the front ahead
put your hat your hand under his butt
nah he's almost as big as me this is the
Train let's do any leg don't overdo it
with your back you give up your clevy
wait a min yeah good mask
all right with me to Miami right now
we're ready to swim
are you ready to Flynn good
pretty that happen carry enough let's go
[Music]
[Music]
we had such a late morning you only have
about two hours of sunlight so we make
the best out of these two hours
[Music]
[Music]
was awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here in Sicily
okay see you
thank you
enjoy about 22 hours 2 hours of beach
fun say goodbye to the ocean well this
has actually been one of the most
relaxed vacations I've had in a long
time
what's the occasion that we take I don't
know why I always feel so stressed out
on vacation I don't know why even on the
cruise I felt kind of stressed out maybe
it's a number of people we always travel
with a lot of stress to draw it's kind
of like well I don't want to overstep my
boundaries I want to make everyone on
this trip happy they want to do that
they want to do this I want to do this
they want to do that so you're always
kind of stressed out by it it's like
social consciousness of needing to make
everyone happy make everyone have an
equal vacation time I guess so now it's
just us and coming back to a place I'm
somewhat familiar with I don't know my
guards are down so happy that's good
because every time we were on vacation I
always see that you're so stressed and
it kind of makes me stressed it makes me
not enjoy my vacation as much either
because I see how you're acting and I'm
like just let go just relax enjoy the
vacation I always tell you somebody's
finally happening else now oh man I just
broke
[Music]
what's next I'm not your tour guide
I'm how long I will probably know Joey
munch ah Selena toured I know we were
walking down the season find the shower
so we're just walking and walking if you
ask me she's like so we're we going on
like you know I live here I'm following
the pretty building so I got lost and
I'm down I'm down with that
going back little stress things I mean
you have an agenda that is add stress so
if you want to keep it stress-free so
just kind of aimlessly walk around and
not know where we're going
I'm leaving here that's really pretty
anyway because the buildings are boring
and like reflecting sign down in here on
the screen what if you become such a
lighting Pro I learn from the best
not likely
my band is one of those shots where
you're like walking and talking like
yeah you know I don't believe in aliens
you know aliens don't exist like what is
it's an alien and everyone the monocle
we actually go find a restrooms I got a
peek thanks again for coming downtown
with Duncan
[Music]
slow down streak
so yes are you ready for two children
now you are holding the hands of two
children
maybe goodbye it I guess cuz I'm like
okay being a mother of one is scary
already during another getting a mix
while you're raising the first one it's
like I know what I'm getting those are
you get because it's connecting the
trusting how helpful you've been with
Aiden you keep ready
I guess nice if you're ready to what do
I use you baby daddy I think I'm ready
to be a dad I think I've had enough
practice of Isaac and being with Aidan
no because I miss out on the ages of 1 2
3 was Isaac but seeing how Aidan is and
something helps to hang out Aidan in
life to see him grow and see him learn
things like that's really fascinating I
feel like you know I sure if you're
ready to see someone grow you're willing
to give yourself to help someone else
develop themselves for those for the
life that's ahead of them I feel like
you're ready to be a parent and so I've
been feeling that way for like longest
time now so it's time to the circuit a
while to get into the whole like having
a Sheila
[Music]
[Music]
there's a lot like turnover see change
again the suitcase is side by side now
what y'all doing look like y'all are
drunker Eddie we're we going out
[Music]
all right we're going to go through some
alligators today and oh my goodness
oh no no let's not do that Aiden